Die SV Elversberg mischen auch nach dem 0-0 gegen den HSV weiter im Aufstiegsrennen der 2. Bundesliga mit. Wohin soll es denn jetzt noch gehen? Der Karlsruher SC hingegen versumpft immer mehr im Tabellen-Niemannsland der Liga und blickt bereits auf einen kommenden Umbruch im Sommer. Darüber spreche ich jetzt in diesem Zweitligaschwerpunkt mit Journalist Marc Drumm vom SR und KSC-Experte Jörn Kreuzer. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, wäre lang genug für Geli Landgraf. Marc Grapf, Martin Farka.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Rasenfunk und damit zur Ligatur, zur Zweitligaligatur der Männer. Bevor ich mich vorstelle, bevor ich die Gäste vorstelle, eine ganz, ganz wichtige technische Sache, eine Hausbeteilung. Es geht um die Kontoumstellung. Denn die Bankverbindung des Rasenfunk hat sich geändert. Das ist ganz wichtig. Alle registrierten SupporterInnen sollten dazu auch eine Mail erhalten haben. Wir haben aber mitbekommen, die ist bei einigen im Spam gelandet. Guckt also unbedingt da nochmal nach, wenn ihr noch nichts bekommen habt. Ihr müsst bitte jetzt, jetzt eure Daueraufträge umstellen. Es bleiben noch so rund anderthalb Monate, dann gibt es das alte Konto nicht mehr. Und es wäre natürlich sehr schade, wenn da die Daueraufträge verloren gehen würden. Die neue Kontoverbindung und noch ein, zwei Details findet ihr in den Show Notes zu dieser Folge. Also da könnt ihr euch das einmal rauskopieren, gar kein Stress. Aber das ist natürlich ganz wichtig, dass ihr da am Ball bleibt und diesen Podcast weiterhin unterstützen könnt. So, nun zur Vorstellung. Ich bin Marc Schwitzki. Ich führe heute wieder durch diese Zweitligasendung. Ich wechsle ja immer mit Eva. Heute bin ich wieder dran. Und ich bin freier Journalist, vor allen Dingen beim LBB zu lesen und beim Podcast HerthaBase zu hören. Und mein erster Gast ist wohnhaft in Hamburg, aber seit vielen Jahrzehnten schon Karlsruher SC-Fan, unser Mann für Haus auf Karlsruhe. Grüß dich, Jörn Kreuzer.
Hallo. Moin in die Runde. Schön, wieder hier zu sein.
Ich freue mich auch. Wir hatten ja noch nicht das Vergnügen. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Gast 2 ist ein Rasenfunk-Debutant gleichzeitig. Er ist seit zehn Jahren Reporter des Saarländischen Rundfunks für die SV Elversberg. Also auch da schon einiges mitgemacht, aber ehrlich gesagt gefühlt eine Positivgeschichte, wenn ich das von außen so betrachte. Und er hat einen ganz fantastischen Vornamen, Marc Drumm, grüß dich.
Ich freue mich über den Vornamen. Dass ich mit 47 noch ein Debüt feiern kann, ist auch irgendwie cool.
Oder? Aber dafür ist die 2. Liga auch da. Da kann man im hohen Alter auch nochmal…
Gott sei Dank gibt es die.
Ich sag dir, ich sag dir. So, bevor wir sportlich werden, der wöchentliche Hinweis. So sprecht es mir doch nach. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich allein durch die Spenden der HörerInnen, beispielsweise dieses Mal genannt von Sebastian, Sebastian H., Max, Lennart und Evan, bei denen wir uns alle samt bedanken wollen. Die Spenden finanzieren nicht nur den Lebensunterhalt von Max, sondern ermöglichen auch, dass die Gäste ein Honorar bekommen und Menschen wie ich und Eva den Podcast ebenfalls moderieren können, Max also auch entlasten können. Wenn ihr das unterstützen wollt, dann schaut mal auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubvorbei. Und nun werden wir sportlich und wollen über die Lage der Liga reden. Der 2. Bundesliga nach dem 27. Spieltag, auch die 2. Liga, ja, schert so langsam in den Endspurt ein. Und beginnen würde ich gerne mit der neuen Spannung im Abschießkampf. Jörn, du hast da so ein bisschen drauf geguckt, das ist wieder ein bisschen enger zusammengerückt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich denke, dass der Sieg von Ulm einiges verändert hat in der Tektonik, weil die ja, glaube ich, bis auf einen Punkt rangesprungen sind, auf Braunschweig. Und gleichzeitig spielen die Unentschieden gegen Münster im direkten Duell. Und ich denke, da wird in den nächsten Wochen einiges auf die Liga zukommen. Ich habe jetzt natürlich auch die KSC-Spiele gegen alle unten gesehen. Und ich fand eigentlich schon Münster mit am stabilsten, sage ich mal. Die gefallen mir auch immer noch spielerisch am besten, mit der besten Idee. Und ich muss aber zu meiner Schande gestehen, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass der Trainerwechsel doch so einen krassen Effekt hat in Ulm. Ich hätte gedacht, die machen da erst mal einen Fehler. Ob es langfristig ein Fehler ist, wird man sehen. Aber dass sie gegen uns zum Beispiel einen Punkt holen und jetzt gewinnen, ist, glaube ich, auch entscheidend, dass Ulm jetzt so ein bisschen die Kurve nach oben bekommt und es überhaupt noch mal spannend wird. Ich habe es vorhin auch angeguckt. Letzter Spieltag ist, glaube ich, Ulm Münster in Ulm.
Korrekt.
Da wird man sehen.
Das ist richtig. Ich habe auch gedacht, das ist so eine Kurzschlossreaktion mit Trainer Wörle, der entlassen wurde. Der Lechleiter hat ja da übernommen. Wie du sagst, haben wir 2 zu 1 gegen Darmstadt gewonnen. Vier Punkte jetzt unter dem neuen Trainer in zwei Spielen. Das passt. Münster, 15. Eintracht, Braunschweig, 16. Da haben sie sich mit 1 zu 1 getrennt. Damit trennen auch diese beiden Mannschaften weiterhin drei Punkte. Wobei man sagen muss, dass Münster das deutlich bessere Torverhältnis hat als Braunschweig. Und das ist ja dann im Abschließkampf gerne auch mal wie so ein vierter Punkt bei Punkt-Gleichstand. Das wird Braunschweig nicht mehr einholen können. Und Marc, eine Mannschaft schickt sich an jetzt auch nochmal mit zum Mischen der Jan aus Regensburg.
Tatsächlich. Und das ist ja der nächste Gegner von der SV Elversberg. Deswegen haben wir da schon ein bisschen drauf geguckt. Es ist irgendwie überraschend, dass da so ein bisschen Dynamik reinkommt. Ich würde aber ganz gern was zu Jan noch sagen. In Sachen Preußen Münster, den Eindruck kann ich total teilen. Das ist die Mannschaft, die mir auch mit Abstand am besten gefallen hat. Geht auch immer über die Spiele, was man mit Elversberg dann macht. Und spricht auch, wie das Torverhältnis ist, aber so rein fußballerisch im Vergleich zu den anderen drei, fand ich da schon echt einen deutlichen Unterschied. Deswegen glaube ich auch auf die Sicht, auf die lange Strecke auch, dann kommen wir wieder zu Regensburg, glaube ich, dass die da über dem Strich bleiben. Oder ich würde fast sagen, auch bleiben sollten, weil sie einfach, ich finde, coole Runde spielen.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Ich habe sie bislang in einem Spiel über 90 Minuten gesehen. Das war gegen Hertha, da haben sie auch sehr gut ausgesehen. Gleichzeitig hat Hertha gegen alle da unten irgendwelche Probleme gehabt und hat ja sogar gegen den Jahren verloren. Also dementsprechend, was soll das schon heißen? Aber auch da, finde ich, hat Preuß und Münster eben einen sehr gefestigten Eindruck gemacht. Regensburg hat jetzt sehr überraschend das Heimspiel gegen Nürnberg gewonnen. Jetzt nicht unbedingt verdient. Die haben da auch sehr wenig, sehr viel gemacht, haben das Ergebnis noch gedreht und mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen und haben jetzt noch 5 Punkte Abstand auf Braunschweig. Die spielen übrigens am 31. Spieltag noch gegeneinander. Also auch da wird die Hütte brennen, auch da kann Regensburg dann nochmal richtig nahe rankommen. Selbst wenn es am Ende nicht reichen sollte, finde ich, dass Regensburg dann doch vielleicht ein bisschen glücklicher auf die Saison gucken kann, weil zwischenzeitlich sah das ja schon so aus, als ob man– ja, blamieren ist ein großes Wort als Aufsteiger. Man hat ja vielleicht auch nicht viel erwartet und trotzdem…
Es sieht nicht immer besser aus, aber es liest sich wieder besser.
Genau, man könnte mit erhobenem Hauptes vielleicht rausgehen. Ja, apropos erhobene Hauptes vielleicht aus der Rückrunde gehen. Ich habe einen Punkt mitgebracht und zwar, Hertha spürt den Leiteffekt. Jörn, du hast es jetzt gesehen. Leider gegen den KSC wurde ein 3 zu 1 gefeiert. Hertha holt damit den ersten Heimsieg und das erste Mal 2 Siege in Folge seit Oktober 2024. Das sagt einiges aus und es sind nun 8 Punkte Abstand auf Rang 16. Die ärgsten Abstiegssorgen wurden jetzt also überwunden, ja auch schon durch das 5 zu 1 gegen Braunschweig. Hertha natürlich so mein Schwerpunkt, deswegen dachte ich, verliere ich dazu mal ein paar Worte, weil es vielleicht die Leute interessiert, denn die Nummer scheint sich jetzt einigermaßen zu stabilisieren und das liegt eben an Stefan Leithel, würde ich behaupten. Das Debüt gegen Nürnberg hätte bereits ein Sieg sein können, bis müssen. Gegen Schalke hat man die erste Halbzeit verschlafen, war aber in der zweiten auch so gespielt, dass man das nicht verlieren muss.
Und jetzt?
Und jetzt, Marc lächelt schon wissend, dann gab es den absoluten 0-4-Totalers-Halb gegen die Elversberg. Aber ich finde auch da, das war das einzige Spiel unter Stefan Leithel, wo man die Mannschaft eben nicht wiedererkannt hat, denn danach gab es ja eben das 5 zu 1 gegen Braunschweig, eine klare Reaktion und jetzt dann eben das auch insgesamt verdiente, 3 zu 1 gegen den KSC. Man hat also tatsächlich die Wände bekommen. Marc, du hättest da auch nicht dran geglaubt, oder nach dem 0 zu 4 in Elversberg?
Also ich habe das Spiel da live im Stadion gesehen und war wirklich, wie will ich denn sagen, also weil du von Trainer-Effekt sprichst, er hat dann tatsächlich wahrscheinlich erst einen Bus auf der Heimfahrt eingesetzt nach Elversberg. Also das war tatsächlich wirklich erschreckend, wie unterlegen Herr da gespielt hat. Und ich habe immer so gegenüber gesessen und auf die Fans geguckt, die direkt hinter der Trainerbank saßen und dachte, ey Mensch, ich habe die Kilometer mal nachgezählt, da in das kleine Elversberg, in das kleine Stadion, wir haben nicht, also es gibt nicht mal einen Bahnhof in Elversberg, ihr tut euch das an und dann gibt es hier eine, in einer schweren Lage eine derartige, also es fühlte sich wie Arbeitsverweigerung manchmal an, aber das, ich will nicht sagen, dass das 4-0 noch klimpfig war, aber ja, ich habe sie mir genau auf dem Schirm, aber boah, das war so klar und das war so enttäuschend. Ich weiß noch irgendwo Mitte der ersten Halbzeit, ich glaube, nach dem 3-0 hat er sie alle mal zusammengerufen. Das war total ein mega Bild, was man selten sieht, wo der auch gesagt hat, pass auf, keine Ahnung, alles nochmal her, alles auf Null und bitte lasst uns hier irgendwie erhoben in der Hauptsitzung. Sie haben echt Glück gehabt, dass sie in der zweiten Halbzeit ein bisschen Duz im Auge gemacht haben. Die haben die wirklich an die Wand gespielt, das war echt extrem.
Absolut, rabisch-schwarzer Tag, der aber vielleicht zwei gute Folgen hatte. Das eine ist, dass man in der zweiten Halbzeit das System für sich entdeckt hat, denn da hat man, um mehr defensive Sicherheit zu gewinnen, auf dieses 3-4-1-2 umgestellt. Das ist bis heute das System, und in dem wurden dann ja auch die guten Spiele und die Punkte geholt. Zum anderen war es vielleicht auch wirklich die Erkenntnis von Stefan Leitl, womit das hier zu tun hat. Also nach dem Spiel konnte sich ja keiner mehr was vormachen. Und ich glaube, dass dann vielleicht manchmal so eine Zäsur dann auch eben hilft. So, und wie gesagt, danach lief es deutlich besser. Man hat jetzt mehr diesen Umschaltfokus, und der funktioniert sehr gut. Der spielt vor allen Dingen Fabian Reese in die Karten, der zusammen mit Derry Sheeran da vorne diese sehr schnelle Doppelspitze spielt und der nach seiner langen Verletzung und ein paar Wochen des Aufbaus wirklich wieder in Hochform unterwegs ist. Jörn, wie blickt man als, ja, dein Gegner auf so einen Spieler, der ihm da zwei Dinge einschenkt?
Naja, beim zweiten Tor war ja da Marcel Franke leider ein guter Sturmpartner, der den Pfeiler zu kurz zurückspielt. Und ja, also ich glaube, es liegt schon, also man merkt deutlich, dass Hertha auch Fabian Reese gebraucht hat, auch für die einfach für die Struktur im Team und auch für den Weg nach vorne, sage ich mal. Und man hat aber trotzdem ja nach dem, also es stabilisiert sich, finde ich auch. Aber man hat trotzdem nach dem Gegentor, das ja wirklich aus dem Nichts kam durch den Elfmeter, auch gemerkt, dass es möglicherweise auch hätte kippen können, ohne dass ich sagen will, wir hätten da einen Punkt verdient gehabt. Aber ja, Hertha müsste aus dem gröbsten raus sein. Jetzt vor allem auch nach dem überzeugenden Auftritt gegen Darmstadt.
Ja, ich finde insgesamt, finde ich, dass die Mannschaft wacher wirkt, galliger wirkt, einen klareren Plan unter Stefan Leithel hat. Und Stefan Leithel, glaube ich, dieser Mannschaft und diesem Verein mit seiner Art gut tut. Ich glaube, also Stefan Leithel ist kein riesiger Menschenfänger, aber das ist, glaube ich, zum einen ein sehr guter Fußballlehrer und er hat so eine stoische Ruhe und ist aber auch sehr ambitioniert in seiner Ruhe. Also ich glaube, ich wüsste nicht, wie man unter Stefan Leithel abheben soll. Ich glaube, das grätscht er sofort ab in dieser Mannschaft und schafft dadurch eine Gier und Hunger, den man unter Christian Fjell selten gesehen hat, der das schöne Spiel wollte und dann vielleicht manchmal auf die kleinen Details im Kampf. Wie nennt es Stefan Leithel immer, die Prioritäten der 2. Liga annehmen? Das tut diese Mannschaft jetzt unter Stefan Leithel. Eine Mannschaft, die das aktuell vielleicht nicht mehr so tut, ist eben der SV Darmstadt 98, der weiß sich viel gerade schon namentlich. Das ist für mich der dritte Punkt, der sich langsam in der Saison-Endphase herauskristallisiert. Dieser Kohfeldt-Hype, der es zwischendurch gab, wo alle sich verwundert die Augen lieben und sagen, wie kann das eigentlich sein, der ebbt jetzt langsam wieder ab. Man hat jetzt 2 zu 1 gegen Ulm verloren und seit Jahreswechsel nur zwei Spiele gewonnen. Also von zehn Partien, zwei Siege, ein Unentschieden, sieben Niederlagen. Krofeld sagt, ich zitiere, systematisch von der Organisation, dem Herauspielen von Chancen, dem Verhindern von Torstellungen, da gehören wir, das muss ich so sagen, zur Top 6 der Liga. Wir bringen die Spiele aber nicht zu Ende. Marc, kann es so einfach sein?
Also auch da bleibt das Beispiel. Ich glaube, die Kurve ging steil nach oben und dann war tatsächlich Elversberg in Darmstadt zu Gast. Und ich war sehr gespannt und sehr skeptisch aus Elversberger Sicht, dass da was zu tun ist, weil ich die Darmstädter, ich bin im Nebenruf noch Regisseur von der Bundesliga und war in Karlsruhe, glaube ich. Die haben davor gegen Karlsruhe irgendwie gespielt. Also ich habe sie gesehen und dachte, boah, diese Mannschaftspiel total verändert, mega stabil, hat mega Spaß gemacht, zuzugucken. Vielleicht nehme ich jetzt auch das falsche Spiel, aber ich habe sie vorher gesehen und dachte, boah, das wird echt eine harte Nummer. Dann noch am Böllenfalttor, dann noch mit dem Effekt des neuen Trainers. Und dann sehe ich da eine Mannschaft, die wirklich in dem Spiel mich echt enttäuscht hat. Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Hertha. Also Elversberg hat 3-0 da gewonnen und auch das völlig verdient. Und ich glaube, das war tatsächlich sogar ab dem Spieltag begann die Serie, die du gerade zitiert hast. Und ganz ehrlich, ich überlege das immer so mit Systemfragen. Und auch da war ganz viel Einstellung. Da waren früh Köpfe, die unten waren, wo ich nicht gesehen habe, dieses Stadion, diese Stimmung. Pass auf, es läuft doch nicht irgendwie richtig, aber wir probieren zumindest dagegen zu halten. Und wenn diese Tendenz– ich habe die Spieler, die jetzt nicht jedes Einzelne verfolgt, wenn die sich sofort gesetzt hat– die waren tatsächlich ohne Chance. Und wenn diese Spirale nach unten weitergeht, dann müsste man auf das Punktekonto gucken. Aber ich glaube, was haben sie denn? 31. Es sind noch ein paar Spieltage. Also ich will nicht unken, aber das kann mal ganz bös auch in eine ganz fiese Richtung gehen.
Florian Kohfeldt denkt zumindest nicht ganz anders. Er sagt, das ist ein Vorsprung, aber es ist keiner, bei dem ich sage, wir planen für die neue Saison. Wir müssen dringend...
Nee, gerade so wie die aktuelle Performance in die Formkurve und dementsprechend ist ja ein Null Selbstvertrauen da. Echte Verunsicherung und wenn das, ich sag mal, wenn es erst noch ein, zwei Spieltage weitertransportiert, dann bist du im Saisonfinale und dann ist das, dann hast du Spannung im Quadrat.
Und ich glaube, irgendwann passen sich die Leistungen auch den Ergebnissen an. Also ich habe mir die Expected Goals Werte der Spiele, der Negativ-Serie mal angeguckt und es begann, beispielsweise hat man sehr, sehr unglücklich gegen Düsseldorf verloren, man war gegen Paderborn ebenbürtig und dann hatte man auch manchmal so leicht bessere Expected Goals Werte, aber das wird auch immer seltener der Fall. Gegen Ulm jetzt unverdiente Niederlage, aber gegen Köln zum Beispiel war man chancenlos, man hatte gegen Braunschweig kaum was kreiert. Also irgendwann passt sich die Leistung ja einfach an, das ist dann auch die Psychologie dieses Sports. Jörn, du wolltest was sagen.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt in so einem isolierten Dschungel leben würde, ich habe dreimal Darmstadt gesehen diese Saison und dreimal, da kann ich Marks Eindruck wirklich teilen, dachte ich, okay, beim zweiten Mal vielleicht nicht mehr, da waren wir selber schwach, aber bei dem Spiel im Wildpark dachte ich auch, wow, und Christian Eichner hat nach dem Spiel auch gesagt, okay, Leute, wir haben hier gerade einen Aufstiegskandidaten verabschiedet.
Dann war das das in Karlsruhe, okay, ja.
Genau, und dann habe ich da…
Wirklich gut.
Und dann habe ich hospidiert, dann habe ich hospidiert Anfang Dezember in Bremen beim Pokalspiel gegen Darmstadt. Ich lag vielleicht auch an Bremen, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich dachte mir, was veranstaltet den Darmstadt mit denen jetzt 90 Minuten? Und Schuhden kamen in die Mixzone und war so überzeugt von dem Plan von Florian Kohfeldt, dass ich mir dachte, okay, wenn die wirklich so in jedes Spiel gehen, die fressen alle auf in der Rückrunde. Aber ja, keine Ahnung. Und…
Ja, es bleibt irgendwie ein Rätsel, denn Darmstadt ist erst nichts gelungen, deshalb ja der Trainerwechsel, dann ist ihnen alles gelungen und dann gelang ihnen wieder nichts. Also ich weiß, man weiß überhaupt nicht, wo man die Ligien irgendwie einsortieren soll. Das ist ganz schwierig. Also ich glaube, es gibt kaum ein größeres Leistungsintervall, was man in dieser Saison gesehen hat bei einer Zweitligamannschaft, würde ich behaupten. Dann reden wir doch vielleicht, und dann kommen wir zum ersten Team über eine Mannschaft, die ein eher enges Leistungsintervall hat, wie ich das Gefühl habe. Die SV Elversberg bleibt dann insgesamt doch ganz schön bei sich, Marc. Nach dem 0-0 gegen den Hamburger SV und nun 27 Spieltagen, steht man mit 41 Punkten auf Rang 7, 5 Zähler hinter dem Relegationsplatz. Wie bewertet man denn im Verein die bisherige Saison und die aktuelle Lage?
Also ich mache es mal einfach als kompletten Erfolg, völlig überraschend. Und man wähnt sich auch jetzt, ohne auf das Punktekonto zu schauen, ein bis zwei Schritte weiter als auch in der Vorsaison. Da standen sie punktemäßig auch nicht schlecht da, aber diese Mannschaft– und es ist tatsächlich erstaunlich, wie diese Kontinuität funktioniert– hat wirklich an Stabilität im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr gewonnen, hat ein ganz anderes Auftreten. Ich finde auch– du hast jetzt das 0-0 in Hamburg angesprochen– man spricht immer so über die Offensivstärke, die Spielfreude. Das ist echt Spaß macht zuzuschauen, dass sie Fußball spielen wollen. Und seit zwei, drei Monaten kriegen sie es auf einmal auf die Pfanne, sogar das eigene Tor irgendwie zu vernageln.
Da gräte ich mal kurz rein, denn den Wert habe ich in meiner Recherche auch. Letzte Saison hat man 64 Gegentore kassiert und diese Saison ist man mit aktuell 32 Platz 2 mit Köln und dem HSV. Was ist denn da passiert?
Nur acht Tore in der Fremde, also das ist Liga-Top-Wert. Und ich kann es einfach machen, ich habe vor zwei, drei Wochen mit dem Torhüter gedreht und mit dem Torwartbetreuer, der hat in der Saison angefangen, für jedes zu Null-Spiel ihm einen Ball zu schenken und ihn zu signieren. Immer mit Spieltag etc. drauf. Und mittlerweile hat er dann, ich glaube, vor zwei Wochen, was er nannt, es dürfte 10. oder 11. schon sein.
Oder so eine Garage mit angemietet dafür.
Und das hat total funktioniert. Auf einmal hat er dann gesagt, okay, weil das beim Torhüter funktioniert hat, hat Robin Fellauer, der Kapitän, gesagt, boah, wenn ich mal ein Tor schieße, hätte ich auch mal gerne einen Ball. Und dann fängt er an, Ende des Jahres, auf einmal aus 20 Metern in jedem Spiel, ihm wie Tore zu schießen. Und jetzt hat er auch schon vier Bälle, alles so schöne Distanzschüsse noch. Also, das wäre das einfache Rezept in Elversberg.
Fußballer mit Bällen motivieren, das kann so einfach sein.
Ja, genau. Das muss einfach ein cleverer Betreuer haben. Es gehen halt die Bälle aus in Elversberg, aber die Punkte sind ja da. Nee, ganz seriös, das ist A, es ist gewachsen, B, haben sie sich zum wievielten Mal mega verstärkt. Ich kenne kaum Neuzugänge, die kommen, die Horst Steffen nicht irgendwie in sein System reinpacken kann und stärker machen kann. Und die sind in der Regel zwischen 19 und 22 Jahren und spielen das Ding darunter dazu, ein Gerüst von Menschen, die seit 6, 7 Jahren da sind. Und die Qualität derer– mein Paul Wander ist im Sommer gegangen davor, Nick Voltemade, das ist schon krass, was da schon vorher war. Und jetzt mit Aslani Damar, ich finde Baum überragend in der Defensive. Und dazu das andere Gerüst, die sind noch mal breiter, noch mal stärker geworden ist, können Menschen ausfallen, das denkt man eigentlich gar nicht für Elversberg. Man denkt, okay, dann haben sie vielleicht einen kleinen Kader und wenn mal was passiert, um Gottes willen. Aber die Phase, als sie zum Tabellenführer wurden, da haben auf einmal das komplette Mittelfeld, Fellauer hat gefehlt, Schein hat gefehlt. Also das Herzstück war weg und die werden trotzdem gewinnen. 3-0 in Braunschweigen sind Tabellenführer. Und dann dachte man da auch schon, ja meine Güte, was soll denn dann irgendwie passieren? Also es wirkt so stabil und sind sie nicht mehr. Sie sind jetzt hinten dran, das ist auch völlig gesund. Aber die Art und Weise mit ein, zwei Ausrutschern, sie haben halt ein großes Problem. Sie spielen unfassbar ungern gegen Aufsteiger, weil sie haben es erst fünf Mal gemacht und haben nicht eine Partie gewonnen. Und wenn man sich das irgendwie schön rechnet, will man gar nicht wissen, wie diese Saison gelaufen wäre. Weil all die Mannschaften, über die du zuerst gesprochen hast, Regensburg, Ulm und Münster, fragt man Elversberg nach. Die haben jetzt schon Angst vor dem Sonntag, wenn es gegen Regensburg geht. Aber dann haben sie auch den letzten Aufsteiger hinter sich. Die spielen viel lieber vor 70.000 in Berlin oder 50 gerade in Hamburg. Die haben auch super gespielt vor 50.000 in Kaiserslautern vor drei Wochen. Aber bitte nicht vor 12 oder 15 in Ulm oder in Regensburg.
In so eine Favoritenrolle muss man auch eben erstmal reinwachsen. Aber du sagst, sie haben sich klar verbessert. Es fehlen ja auch nur noch drei Punkte, um besser als in der gesamten Fondsaison zu sein.
Das stimmt, aber tatsächlich von dem ganzen Konstrukt der Mannschaft her, von der Stabilität, auch diese zu Null Spiele sind schon ein Zeichen. Die haben in Hamburg auch, der Kopfball kann noch ein bisschen flacher gehen. Sie haben schon zwei, drei Chancen zugelassen, wo sie Glück hatten. Aber das wirkt schon so, wo ich echt über die letzten Wochen sehr überrascht bin, dass so etwas wie Münster als einziger Ausrutscher passiert, wo sie mal sagen, okay, da greifen sie irgendwie daneben. Was noch so ein bisschen gefühlt, manchmal ist es, dass sie gerade in der zweiten Halbzeit gegen Ende, manchmal das Gefühl, es geht so ein bisschen die Puste und Energie aus. Also die Dinge, die sie verloren haben, haben sie oft so Ende der Saison gegen Schalke zu Hause, wo du sagst, so jetzt noch mal nachlegen, da dachte ich, da kommt nichts mehr. In Hamburg waren es auch die letzten 12, 13 Minuten, wo sie wirklich geschwommen sind, aber dann auch wieder gezeigt haben, wir können auch mal mit 11 Leuten hier uns reinstellen und keulen. Aber generell habe ich irgendwann im Dezember dann tatsächlich auch gesagt, mir fallen nicht viel bessere Mannschaften ein als die SV E. Also mal völlig von der Hand zu weisen, ist es nicht, dass sie vielleicht bis zum Saisonende da mitspielen und tatsächlich scheinen sie das zu machen.
Ja, Horst Scheffen sagte zu dem Thema Kondition, auch dass man ja ab der 80. stehen K.o. war in Hamburg und dementsprechend auch ein bisschen Glück hatte, dann das über die Zeit zu bringen. Aber man ist ja auch ein sehr...
Aber das ist ja das Spiel.
Genau, ich wollte nämlich gerade sagen, in der Laufdiskanz sind sie Platz 3 in der Liga bei den Sprints, Platz 2 bei den intensiven Läufen, Platz 4. Also, offensichtlich geht es kaum besser und dann investiert man ja genug um... Dann darf man auch KO sein zum Ende in eine Partie. Aber man kann offensichtlich Elversberg nicht sagen, ohne im nächsten Schritt Haus Steffen zu nennen. Das ist nun mal der erste Name, den man mit diesem Elversberger Erfolg verbindet. Kannst du sein Wirken noch mal kurz skizzieren? Und wie gelingt es ihm denn, mit so geringen Mitteln solch einen guten, selbstbewussten Fußball spielen zu lassen? Das hört ja irgendwie nicht auf.
Nein, es verbraucht sich nicht. Wir haben jetzt schon wieder über Trainer-Effekte gesprochen, was er auch in Berlin gerade gesagt hat. Was alle über ihn sagen, ist, dass er abgesehen von seiner sportlichen Idee, von seiner Fußballidee, nach vorne Fußball spielen zu lassen, dass er ein Menschenfänger ist. Und das ist oft gebraucht. Aber ich erlebe ihn fast Woche für Woche, A im persönlichen Kontakt und B auch im Kontakt mit der Mannschaft. Und im Saarland sind die Wege relativ kurze und man hat tatsächlich eine Nähe auch zu den Spielern. Und ich habe es selten erlebt, jetzt in den 15 Berufsjahren auch mit anderen Vereinen und bin jetzt seit 2016 mit der SWE betraut, dass sich Ersatzspieler auch überhaupt nicht beschweren. Also, dass du nie irgendwas hörst von wegen, boah, ich sitze, ich werde ungeduldig, ich sitze seit 5 Spielen auf der Bank, was weiß ich was, der treibt quer oder sowas. Seine oberste Priorität und seine oberste Regel ist, zuerst kommt der Mensch und dann kommt der Sportler und das zieht er komplett durch in einer ruhigen, mit einer gesunden Autorität, aber er hat eine Nähe zu den Spielern und also viele, die auch für Regionalliga-Zeiten schon gab es drei, vier, die haben verlängert um vier Jahre. Also ihr kennt vielleicht Regionalliga auch, das ist ein Sprungbrett, da macht jeder ein Jahr und ist weg und wie auch immer. Die haben nur gesagt, ey, unter ihm, also wo soll ich besser spielen als unter ihm? Ich will mich total wohl, ich will hier und das so Leute wie Luca Schnellbacher, Manuel Pfeil, Robin Fellauer, die sind die ganze Strecke mit ihm gegangen. Also Manuel Pfeil kam drei Tage vor ihm, vor sieben Jahren, vor Nürnberg 2 oder sowas, also er hätte sich nie träumen lassen, 2. Liga zu spielen und Horst Schöffen sagt auch. Und die Spieler wissen auch, dass sie auch dem Verein ein bisschen was zu verdanken haben. Die wären vielleicht in anderen Konsolidationen niemals, hätten die jetzt in Hamburg vor 50.000 gespielt. Also da ist eine Dankbarkeit da. Also es ist tatsächlich, er hat eine menschliche Art und Weise, die es erlaubt, über so lange Zeit tatsächlich erfolgreich zu sein. Und ich finde tatsächlich, das kommt als erstes und dann kannst du denken, okay, der hat vielleicht sogar noch Ahnung von Fußball und hat sich Schritt für Schritt ein Team aufgebaut und mit dem Trainer, der war am Anfang ganz alleine, mit Co-Trainer Rudi Thömmes und hat mittlerweile tatsächlich mal einen professionellen Stab. Und er macht das ja auch in Elversberg. Also Elversberg ist kein, es gibt kein riesen Trainingsgelände, es gibt keine riesen Infrastruktur. Die bauen da Ortseingang, Dorfeingang, ja dieses Stadion parallel irgendwie hoch auf 15.000 Menschen. Das wusste eh keiner, wie soll das überhaupt funktionieren da. Und die haben gar keinen Trainingsplatz da. Also die sind schon in der Zeit, wo Horst Steffen da ist, sind sie jetzt auf dem, glaube ich, 4. oder 5. Trainingsgelände. Wir haben sie in Frankreich was angemietet, 30 Kilometer entfernt mal. Die waren in einem kleinen Vorort von Neunkirchen, in Hainitz, kennt kein Mensch, ist ein Platz, da sind die im Aufstiegsjahr noch, sind die mit den Bussen, also im Drittliga-Auftiegsjahr, mit 3, 4, 9er-Bussen und die Spieler fahren die Busse da 5 Kilometer rüber. Das ist, das prägt halt schon alle und die gehen den Weg mit und die fahren über die Baustellen. Die wohnen seit 3, 4 Jahren in Containern. Jetzt sind sie in St. Ingbert, ein bisschen größere Stadt und dann haben sie aber auch dort ein kleines Containerdörfchen. Also es ist so, das ist so, wir sagen es ist ein gallisches Dorf, aber das ist so zusammengewachsen und es wächst halt nach oben zusammen, dass da so ein Zusammenhalt ist, dass das wirklich schon so lange so, auch tatsächlich auch so optisch schön anzusehen, funktioniert. Und dann als letztes nur, dann erkläre ich den Mann aber nicht mehr, er kam zusammen mit Ole Brog und das ist tatsächlich ein Team. Und der als Sportdirektor, das ist relativ einfach gesagt, Ole hat mir gesagt, ich weiß halt, welche Spieler Horst braucht, um erfolgreich zu sein und welche er will. Und die versuche ich ihm zu holen, Punkt.
Ich wollte dir mich gerade sagen, also zum einen, man möchte ja eigentlich auch, man als Journalist möchte ja immer so kritisch reinpiksen, aber es ist gerade bei der SV Elversberg gefühlt nicht möglich.
Geht auch los, das können wir noch machen.
Ja, aber es muss ja auch gar nicht notgedrungen sein, aber normalerweise kennen wir das ja alle, auch bei so Fußballvereinen, es gibt immer ein Aber, aber bei der Elversberg gibt es das Aber-Gefühl gerade nicht, weil es eben gefühlt nur in eine Richtung seit vielen Jahren geht. Aber das hätte mich nämlich interessiert. Steffen allein wird ja nicht für den sportlichen Erfolg sorgen können. Da wird es ja eine Person um ihn herum geben, die auch dafür sorgen, dass Elversberg sich stetig weiterentwickelt. Du hast jetzt Oloburg genannt. Gibt es da noch andere Personen? Beispielsweise den Vereinspräsidenten oder so. Dieses Eingeschworen, das muss ja auch durch die Gremien getragen werden.
Die Gremien haben sie auch vor ein paar Jahren umgestellt, in Anführungszeichen der Entwicklung von wirklichen Dorfvereinen. Das ist nicht allzu lange her. Sie haben eine lange Zeit in der Regionalliga verbracht und sind da sozusagen gewachsen und immer wieder am Aufstieg gescheitert. Zwei in meiner Relegation mit Michael Biesinger, ich weiß, in 15, 16 glaube ich. Und waren 2. oder 3. Es gab so 10 Jahresregionalliga Südwest-Tabelle. Da war Platz 1 die SV Elversberg. Sie waren schon sehr lange da erfolgreich, haben aber kurz davor dann Oberliga, Verbandsliga, Bezirksliga noch, glaube ich, rund um die 90er, wenn die irgendwie, also in den 90ern gespielt. Und dann hat ein Unternehmer im Saarland gesagt, pass mal auf, ich würde mal gerne probieren, wie weit komme ich denn mit meinem Geld und mit den Bezirksligisten im Profifußball? Und das ist Frank Holzer, war auch mal Trainer in Saarbrücken, war auch mal Fußballprofi in Braunschweig. Und er hat sich diesem Verein angenommen und hat, da war dieses Stadion, hat irgendwie drei Reihen Tribüne gehabt und sonst ein paar Leitplanken, weil es direkt an der Straße ist. Und hat das einfach sukzessive aufgebaut und hat irgendwann es an seinen Sohn übergeben, ähnlich wie seine Firma. Und der hat dann relativ schnell, so ab den 2010er-Jahren, sich dann mal einen Vorstand geholt, mal noch jemand da rein. Einmal kamen Sportlichwahlen. Es ist also gewachsen, auch ein bisschen anders als unser Brücken, heimlich, still und leise. Aber haben sich Strukturen geschaffen und die haben, die einen haben genug mit dem Stadion zu tun. Und die lassen dementsprechend auch Ole Bog und Horst Steffen arbeiten. In völliger, es ist eine klare Aufgabenverteilung. Und man meint, was sollen sie machen? Es läuft total erfolgreich. Die einbauen, so schnell wie man es kaum glauben kann, für saarländische Verhältnisse und im kleinen Rahmen und im Spielbetrieb und mit all den Auflagen und da ist direkt ein Naturschutzgebiet. Und jeder Parkplatz war total eng, dass überhaupt was passiert. Eigentlich dürfte man gar nicht expandieren an der Stelle. Aber sie kriegen dieses Stadion. Es geht immer weiter, zwar in kleinen Schritten, manchmal, aber es geht immer weiter. Und es ist mittlerweile wirklich ein großes Team, was nach außen hin gut zusammenarbeitet. Und sportlich sind es halt die beiden. Wenn immer um Worben, auch Ole Brok hat diverse Angebote in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren auch schon ausgeschlagen. Auch da waren Bundesligisten dran, ihn zu holen. Und auch da ist, glaube ich, so was, wo sie wissen, boah, also ich finde, es ist eigentlich immer nah am Denkmal dran. Aber zusammen in der Konstellation, das ist jetzt das siebte Jahr, zu arbeiten und dann zu sagen, also die werden im ganzen Land, ich bin mit Horst Steffen mal für den Badtag, bin ich über den Marktplatz gegangen, weil er immer gern Käse kauft und so was. Und da kommen also die Leute und dann Moin, der Volkstrainer! Das ist halt umdorfen. Dann strahlt der und lächelt und freut sich und sagt, oh, guck mal da, das ist nicht schön. Und ich glaube, das ist ihm viel wichtiger als noch ein paar Kröten extra irgendwo. Ich glaube, der hat schon einige Angebote abgeschlagen oder ausgeschlagen, um in Elversberg zu bleiben. Wird aber nächstes Jahr spannend. Ich glaube, sein Vertrag läuft nächsten Sommer aus und dann so mit Blick auf seinen, also er ist immer noch jung geblieben, aber ist für ihn dann wahrscheinlich auch so eine letzte, vorletzte Entscheidung, mache ich es jetzt hier durch oder will ich noch einmal? Er kommt ja irgendwie aus Krefeld und er pendelt und seine Familie ist halt nicht in Saarbrücken, also er lebt mittlerweile in Saarbrücken. Und ob er das noch weiter mitmachen möchte, aber bislang funktioniert das total gut, warum also ändern. Aber das wird so die nächste spannende Personalie und die alles entscheidende, glaube ich, aus Elversberg. So Anfang der neuen Saison, machen wir ja gerne Journalisten. Dürfen wir mal fragen, was der Vertrag macht? Haben Sie schon gesprochen? Das machen wir sehr gespannt.
Das hätte ich mich nämlich gefragt, als ich gesehen habe, dass dein Vertrag 2026 dann im Sommer ausläuft. Ob er nochmal mit dann, ja, 57, glaube ich, nochmal eine neue Herausforderung sucht oder ob er bei der SVE einfach seine sportliche Heimat gefunden hat und dann den Frank Schmidt macht und dann ist es das einfach.
Ich bin immer so hin und her gerissen, aber ich glaube irgendwie, warum sollte er es nicht machen? Also er hat irgendwie 4 Jahre in der Regionalliga gewartet, um dann aufzusteigen und seit er jedes Spiel– und er sagt es bis heute, er sagt auch in dem Hamburg-Spiel, ich nehme das nicht als selbstverständlich. Also wie viel geborgen er ist auch so. Ich finde, er steht so im Leben und weiß, dass es wichtige Dinge gibt und mit ihm kann man sich plenten unterhalten, wenn das Mikrofon aus ist und zwar nicht über Fußball. Und der weiß schon, was er da an der SV Elversberg auch hat. Und umgekehrt wissen sie es, was sie an ihm haben. Vielleicht haben sie es einfach gefunden und es soll so sein.
Diese Geschichten gibt es manchmal auch im Fußball. Es sind nicht immer alles Suchende, die dann weiterziehen. Elversberg, du hast es eben schon erwähnt, mausert sich ja immer mehr zu so einem beliebten Ausbildungsverein für junge Talente. Elias Baumhorst erwähnt, der ist von Eintracht Frankfurt geliehen, Fesnik Aslanien, Mohamed Damar sind von Hofmeijm geliehen. Spieler wie Schmal sind festgewechselt, Petkov. Sie profitieren von ihren Leihen oder von ihren festen Wechseln in Saarland sehr. Will der Verein darüber auch eine Identität schaffen? Oder wie definiert die SV E das Spielerprofil für sich, was sie unbedingt haben wollen?
Generell sind sie eine Mannschaft, die nicht zwingend auf Größe geht. Das nimmt er in Kauf. Wenn man sich Standardwerten anguckt, da ist auf alle Fälle Platz nach oben. Gerade in Schlussphasen wie Hamburg, wo alles da rein segelt, mache ich mir ein bisschen Sorgen. Aber das passt nicht zum Stil von Horst Steffen, zu diesem laufintensiven, passintensiven. Also gerne Nick Volgemade, der mit dem Ball umgehen kann und trotzdem 2 Meter groß ist, aber das gibt es halt auch selten. Sie haben aus einer Note Tugend gemacht. Klar würden die, wenn sie das doppelte Vermögen haben, würden sie sagen, da legen wir halt noch 2, 3 Kröten drauf und dann verpflichten wir ihnen. Und aus dieser Entwicklung Volgemade, da waren sie schon, da dachte man, boah, der hat sie mit in die 2. Liga hochgeschossen, hat in diesem Drittliga ja, war erst Reserve und musste hier reinspielen und hat da diese Entwicklung gemacht zum wirklichen, boah, aus dem kann was werden. Und gut, das ist jetzt so schnell, das konnte keiner ahnen. Aber da war die Frage, oh Gott, was machen die jetzt? Der Volgemade geht weg, wie will man den ersetzen? Das können sie, müssen ja jemanden kaufen, dann kam Paul Wanner. Und dann das gleiche Spiel noch mal und mittlerweile sind sie glaube ich jetzt so safer und sagen, ja okay, es sind jetzt aber Aslany, Damar, Baum, die sind nicht zu halten. Also in meinem Empfinden Baum hat schon in Frankfurt ja vier Jahre unterschrieben, der hat doch gesagt, er will zurück. Da fallen also drei, vielleicht vier Leistungsträger oder drei Leistungsträger auf alle Fälle weg. Das wird dann schon ein bisschen schwerer als nur ein Paul Wanner. Aber irgendwie habe ich so oder alle Vertrauen in dieses System gefasst und sie warten meistens, also selten, dass frühe Wechsel bekannt gegeben werden. Und sie sind, also sie glaubt, sie vertrauen ihrem eigenen System und mittlerweile sagen sie auch, es ist gar nicht mehr so schwer. Also die Anfragen liegen da und dann werden wir genauso gut gucken wie in den anderen Jahren und warum sollten wir auf einmal so komplett daneben liegen. Auch das kann aber mal vorkommen. Du kannst ja wirklich einfach Pech haben oder es verletzt dich einer. Bislang haben sie auch einfach die Menschen geholt und die sind halt tragend. Also wenn die nicht da wären, dann siehst du schon, also die bringen schon spielerische Klasse in dem Jahr rein, was sie nicht hatten. Also Damar, Aslani im 1 gegen 1, das war was. Es ging viel über schnelle Pässe, viel Bewegung, aber so wirklich dann zu sagen, pass auf, ich gebe ihm mal den Ball, vielleicht macht er was Verrücktes. Das gab es in Elversberg in den letzten Saison und in den Jahren zuvor nicht. Und das ist auch ein Schritt, in dem Jahr nach vorne. Das wird dann im Sommer weggehen. Also eins zu eins ersetzt kriegen sie es nicht, aber bislang hat es immer so, irgendwie kriegen sie es wieder hin. Und das glauben sie auch im nächsten Jahr. Also es wird so weitergehen. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich an der Politik was ändern wird.
Zumal bei Leyen weiß man ja, der Abgang kann einen nicht plötzlich treffen. Da weiß man ja, dass man dann wieder vorplanen muss. Aber du sagst es, der Spielstil, der ist in Zahlen auch sehr leicht auszudrücken. Sie sind Platz 17, was Flanken angeht. Also wie du sagst, die Flanken nicht, nur Nürnberg flankt weniger, haben mittlerweile die sechstmeisten Dribblings in der Liga. Also da kommt dieses Dribbling, dieses 1 gegen 1.
War aber viel auch so ein Pet-Kopf oder sowas. Auch Elias Baum, was ja von hinten raus umkurven kann. Also diese Seite generell hat einen großen Anteil.
Und dann bei den Toren Platz 7, also da zeigt sich halt auch dieser mutige Spielstil. Es sind jetzt noch sieben Partien bis Saisonende. Was sind denn jetzt noch die Ziele bis dahin? Also du hast schon gesagt...
Ich will einen Aufsteiger schlagen. Die letzte Chance ist am Sonntag, das will ich nicht hören. Danach haben wir alle sehr reich, glaube ich.
Danach können sie sich in die Sonne legen, sehr gut. Nee, aber jetzt wird man das einzuschätzen, zu wissen, wo man ist und wie groß die Konkurrenz nach oben ist. Und man wird jetzt nicht öfter, ich sehe nicht Haus Steffen nächste Woche sich hinschauen und sagen so. Und jetzt wollen wir den Aufstieg aber auch.
Vorletzter Spieltag hat er gesagt. Wenn es am vorletzten Spieltag noch möglich ist, haben wir abgemacht, dann spricht er vom Aufstieg. Also, er musste noch einen Moment warten. Aber die große Maxime von ihm ist, wir spielen dann am besten, wenn wir den Kopf ausschalten. Und das verlangt, also mir das verlangt, andere mit Sicherheit auch. Aber er formuliert es eigentlich immer noch ganz schön und gibt das seinen Spielern auch weiter und sagt, bitte nicht denken. Lass es einfach so, wir haben es. Es ist auch im Training ganz interessant, die Woche immer so ein bisschen Lieblingselemente der Spiele. Es wird super viel gespielt, wo die Abläufe einschüttert werden, auf kleinem Raum, unter Stress, unter Tempo, gar nicht mal so viel Quantität, aber Qualität. Und das siehst du wirklich eins zu eins im Training und dann halt auf dem Platz.
Und da habe ich auch Hochachtung vor, denn kurz da das Querbeispiel Hertha reinzubringen. Hertha wollte mit Christian Fjell etwas Ähnliches schaffen, was den Stil angeht. Man wollte auch mutigen Ballbesitz Fußball implementieren und hat gesehen, jetzt mal vielleicht fernab von der Personalie, Christian Fjell selbst, wie schwer es ist für solch einen großen Verein, mit diesen Ambitionen, mit diesem Umfeld, mit diesem Druck, die Geduld aufbringen zu können, das durchzuziehen. Ich glaube, wenn du mich fragst, der Trainerwechsel war vollgerichtig, weil man sich in eine Negativ-Spirale begeben hat, aus der man nicht mehr herauskam.
Ich war eher so dieser Mofa-Nofa-Berliner, diese B-Ebene bei dem Wechsel, die hat mich ein bisschen überrascht.
Mich auch, mich auch, aber da hat man irgendwie gesehen, wie schwer es ist für so etablierte große Traditionsvereine, mit all dieser Erwartungshaltung, solch einen Fußball implementieren zu können. Weil den schönen Fußball wollen sie alle spielen, aber schafft man es wirklich. Und ich glaube, man hat dann vielleicht in Elversberg mal diesen Perfect Storm erwischt. Du hast den Trainer, der das spielen lassen will und kann. Du hast aber auch die Zeit und das Umfeld, um so was ganz in Ruhe wachsen zu lassen. Das passiert sehr selten, dass so was zusammenkommt.
Aber auch auf dem Weg gab es mal Punkte in den drei Jahren Regionalliga, wo sie immer obendran gekratzt haben, aber es nicht zu Ende gebracht haben. Auch da waren sie jedes Jahr, gehörten sie zu den Aufstiegsfavoriten. Und da war nicht nur Eitel Sonnenschein. Da haben sie gerade die engen Spieler, die wichtigen, nicht gewinnen können. Das war oft so eine Marke. Pass mal auf, gegen Top-Teams könnte er nicht gewinnen. Mittlerweile lacht er und sagt, das haben wir abgewendet. Mittlerweile können wir gegen die Aufsteiger nicht mehr gewinnen. Also es ist so.
Aber es ist natürlich ein Unterschied, wenn das...
In dem Aufstiegsjahr ist er von seinem Stil ein wenig weggegangen. Also er wechselt sehr wenig. Da hat er etwas mehr gewechselt. Er hat etwas defensiver spielen lassen. Er hat ein bisschen mehr auf Ergebnis gerückt. Er hat auch selbst gesagt, hat ein, zwei Wintereinkäufe dann gemacht, was auch ein bisschen untypischer war. Da kamen Carlo Sickinger auch als Stabilisator. Es wurde auf einmal nicht mehr so high in Fire gespielt, sondern es ging dann auch mal 2-1, 1-0 und 0-0. Aber so ist man dann halt hoch. Und dann war auf einmal wieder das, was er will. Der Kopf ist frei. Boah, wir sind ja neu, keiner erwartet was. Und dann haben sie auch in der 3. Liga, die haben im Februar 17 Punkte Vorsprung gehabt und waren Tabellenführer. Das war ja unfassbar, was sie da gespielt haben. Und dann begannen sie zu denken und dann wurde es wieder hinten raus ein bisschen knapp. Aber wenn ich weiß noch, wirklich Februar und die Tabelle und 17 Punkte als Aussteigervorsprung, das war schon. Und was sie da alles vom Hof gefegt haben, das war schon krass.
Und wo will Elversberg jetzt allgemein hin? Der Aufstieg des Vereins von Liga 4 in Liga 2, wir haben es eben beschrieben, war schon einigermaßen kometenhaft. Man gehört jetzt auch in der 2. Liga zu den besseren Teams. Hat man da für sich so ein Mittel- bis langfristiges Ziel mal öffentlich formuliert?
Nein, das machen sie nicht. Aber sie sagen es auf anderen Ebenen. Das Stadion ist erst Liga-tauglich, wenn es fertig ist. Also das ist kein… Das Wort Heidenheim fiel auch ab und zu. Das ist jetzt schon mal nach dem Motto… Bei denen hat es ja auch funktioniert. Also warum nicht? Und es wäre ja irgendwie so ein bisschen Selbstbetrug, wenn du so oben mitspielst und immer drei Punkte, vier Punkte hast. Zumindest mal sagst, wir sind ja da oben dran. Das kann jetzt auch kein Glück mehr sein. Das ist schon okay. Aber es wäre echt cool, wenn wir das mal halten können. Also ich glaube, diese Positionierung… Und wenn sie jetzt unterschreiben müssten, das geben wir euch mal drei, vier Jahre jetzt. Und da seid ihr, da würden die direkt sagen, machen wir total gerne, weil immer noch ist es nicht… Du hast die Leihspiele angesprochen. Ich glaube schon, dass das vielleicht so ein Schritt ist, wo sie sagen, vielleicht können wir mal in einem Jahr, zwei dann sagen, pass auf, statt Aslani, Baum und Damar zu leihen, leihen wir noch einen und kaufen zwei. Wann kommt der Schritt, um zu sagen, wir werden noch erwachsener und befreien uns ein bisschen von diesem Image noch, wobei sie gar keinen Druck haben, weil es funktioniert ja.
Ja, definitiv. Und mit so einem sportlichen Erfolg kommen da auch sicherlich Wachstumsschmerzen einher, oder? Also wir haben jetzt schon das Stadion öfter angesprochen, also wie geht der Club mit den personellen und infrastrukturellen Ressourcen um, habe ich mich gefragt. Da muss ich ja wahrscheinlich aktuell auf der Geschäftsstelle ganz schön strecken.
Also die haben einfach, ich meine, die haben ja noch ein Nachwuchsleistungszentrum dahinter. Die fahren das ganze Land, die suchen Plätze, wo sie irgendwie hantieren können. Die erste Mannschaft braucht mal in Funktionsgebäude, da ist der erste Baustein auch nicht gebaut. Die haben jetzt gerade mal zwei Trainingsplätze, die durch eine Hauptstraße noch getrennt sind, in St. Ingwerth mal gefunden. Die haben sie renaturiert und da ist aber auch immer fraglich, welcher Rasen geht denn gerade, je nachdem, wie die Temperaturen sind. Also ich glaube, man kann so manchen verwöhnten Profi mal einfach ein paar Wochen nach Elversberg schicken und zu sagen, übrigens so geht es auch. Und die spielen trotzdem, trainieren dann, kommen trotzdem gerne. Aber die sind halt echt in Containern untergebracht und nicht irgendwie luxuriös und was weiß ich, das Parken irgendwo an so einem kleinen Flüsschen. Da müssen wir ein bisschen latschen und dann noch Bälle holen, über die Straße gehen. Also so wie die F-Jugend im Dorf oder so. Das ist dann schon krass. Und da siehst du, dass die also auf Jahre noch keine Angst haben müssen, dass sie irgendwie in einem Monat vergeht, ohne Bauplan, ohne irgendwas fertig zu zählen, ohne eine Abnahme. Die Stellen sich Sponsoren mäßig, die Logen sind ausverkauft. Auch da hat sich was entwickelt. Wer hätte gedacht, Elversberg an der Regionalliga, einen Schnitt von, keine Ahnung, 700 Zuschauern gehabt. Die haben jetzt im Schnitt 10, 11.000. Man fragt sich, wo kommen die her, im kleinen Saarland? Es ist tatsächlich so. Die könnten auch mehr verkaufen. Es entsteht auf dieser Ebene Fan-Kultur. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele in Hamburg waren, aber in Kaiserslautern waren auf einmal zwischen 4.000 und 5.000 aus Elversberg. Die ganze Kurve war voll. Also so viele waren ja bis vor einem Jahr nicht im eigenen Stadion. Also es wächst auf allen Ebenen. Manche würden dann sagen, da dürfte es ein bisschen schneller wachsen und warum sind die immer noch in Containern? Warum haben wir immer noch kein irgendwo im Saarland mal irgendwas platt gemacht und ein geiles Gelände gemacht? Aber es ist halt, was haben sie 5.700 Einwohner in Elversberg? Es ist halt kein Platz mehr da. Saarland ist eng besiedelt. Da ist es halt so bei uns. Und aber die haben unheimlich viele Projekte, müssen aber kreative, smarte Lösungen finden. Und dafür haben sie halt gute Menschen am Werk, die da irgendwie auch Bock drauf haben. Aus Stöffn könnt ihr auch sagen, ich hab mal keinen Bock mehr nach 7 Jahren auf Baustelle. Ich fände es cool in einem Stadion, wo mein Trainerbüro nicht zum 7. Mal wechselt und ich in einem Container sitze, sondern vielleicht irgendwie da in der Chefetage, Fahrstuhl fährt mich auch noch hoch. Die Hüfte ist operiert, ich kann wieder rund laufen, aber Wünsche sind da schon da. Aber die gehen das alle mit, das ist total bewundernswert.
Ein Projekt ist das Stadion an der Kreiselände. Das befindet sich in einem massiven Umbau. Das kostet, habe ich jetzt gelesen. Ich glaube, beim SR 30 Millionen Euro insgesamt.
Wo ist der Plan?
Wo kommt das Geld her? Teilt man sich das mit dem Land, mit der Stadt? Wie funktioniert das?
Da gibt es ein paar Landeszuschüsse, aber wenn im Saarland das Land beteiligt oder mehr die Stadt beteiligt ist, dann geht man ganz schnell nach der Brücke, guckt sich den Ludwigspark an und wer so ein bisschen mitdrucken hat, die Diskussion, das ging bei 6, 7 Jahren, dieses Stadion in dieser Brücke umzubauen. Und es hat nachher, glaube ich, 4-5 Mal so viel gekostet. Es war eine riesen Seifenoper im Saarland. Und da wurde immer drauf verwiesen, guck mal da, fährt man 20 Kilometer die Autobahn Richtung Norden und dann bis in Richtung Osten. Da geht es einfach, da wird gesagt und wird gemacht. Und das ist der Vorteil, dass das Stadion in Vereinshand, in Holzerhand ist. Und deswegen kommt das meiste Geld auch von ihm, auch die die Anschöpfe. Das geht ja in Etappen. Das ist schon vor zehn Jahren. Ist die eine Tribüne gebaut worden, dann hat man geguckt, mir steigt. Spielt eine Regionalliga oben mit, dann wurde die die Fan-Seite neu gemacht. Das ist nicht so, dass sie sagen, wir bauen zwei Jahre jetzt dieses Stadion in Polen. Das ist ein Prozess über zehn Jahre. Und sie haben ihn mal gestoppt, weil sie sagten, okay, wir wollten eigentlich früher aus der Regionalliga raus. Das haben sie halt nicht gemacht. Als sie dann da draußen sind, haben sie halt, okay, dann Next Step. Dann reichen die nächsten Anträge ein. Und bis dahin sind jetzt mittlerweile auch mehr Sponsoren im Boot. Aber es geht ganz viel, dass das auch über die Sponsorengelder geht und man nicht so viel auf Land und vor allem Stadt warten muss. Da gibt es Zuschüsse. Aber genau deswegen geht es auch viel flotter voran als in der Nachbarschaft.
Du hast gerade Saarbrücken erwähnt. Vielleicht da die letzte Frage in dem Elversberg-Part. Saarbrücken war ja nun lange der Platzhirsch im Bundesland. Wie blickt man denn auf Elversberg? Ist man neidisch? Nimmt man das nicht ernst? Wie ist das?
Also die Hardcourser Brückenfans nehmen das weiterhin nicht ernst. Das wird auch immer so bleiben, das ist auch okay. Aber das gesamte Umfeld, die gesamte Wahrnehmung im Saarland hat spätestens mit dem Zweitliga-Aufstieg gesehen, dass man tatsächlich auch, dass man weiterfahren muss, dass man am Ludwigspark wunderbar die Autobahn weiter durchfahren, kommt das nächste Kreuz rechts ab, nächste rechts. Und dann bist du in Elversberg. Auch was die Wirtschaft angeht, ich habe eben die Logen angesprochen. Es ist halt mittlerweile ein Treff zu sagen, wow, wir gehen zu Elversberg, weil Fußballleien sagen, da ist Unterhaltung, da wird cooler Fußball geboten. Das Stadion ist klein, da kommt jetzt die nächste, die Gegend gerade wird nochmal abgerissen, das sieht halt dann doof aus und leer. Und man guckt auf die Baustelle, ein Jahr wahrscheinlich. Aber an sich hat sich in den letzten 2, 3 Jahren spätestens komplett gewandelt, ist etabliert. Und ich glaube wirklich nur noch unter den tiefen blau-schwarzen Fenstern, davon gibt es ganz viele, also Saarbrücker-Fans, die Elversberg nie wahrnehmen werden und nie respektieren werden als Nummer 1, weil sie dann halt sagen, ja mein Gott, das ist das Geld vom Holzer und Retorte und ihr habt keine Tradition und was weiß ich was. Und ja, aber sie haben halt einen Plan. Und das hilft dann manchmal.
Das hilft manchmal. Marc, vielen lieben Dank an der Stelle schon mal. Bleibt uns gerne noch erhalten, denn wir werden jetzt über den KSC reden und da hole ich Jörn dann wieder rein. 37 Punkte, Platz 10, 9 Zähler hinter Rang 3 und 13 vor Rang 16. Man ist nach der Liederlage in Berlin ganz offiziell Niemandsland der 2. Liga angekommen, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und so gefühlt auch als einzige Mannschaft, vielleicht jetzt noch Schalke oder Fürth dabei. Aber ja, und ich glaube, dass auch der Stecker nach unten gezogen ist, macht mich als Fan jetzt nicht traurig, weil wir mit dem Abstieg nichts zu tun haben werden. Aber ich glaube, das Berlin-Spiel hat jetzt definitiv dazu beigetragen, dass man echt gucken muss, wie man vernünftig die Saison zu Ende bekommt, sage ich mal. Weil der Kopf scheint leer zu sein, de facto.
Was ist denn die Gefühlslage des KSC zu dieser Saison? Also nach der Hinrunde war man noch Tabellen-Zweiter, zwei Punkte hinter Spitzenreiter Köln. War klar, dass man das nicht durchhalten werde können, oder ist man dann doch am Ende ziemlich ernüchtert oder enttäuscht sogar?
Schwer zu sagen. Ich sag's mal so, in der Hinrunde gab es auch schon durchwachsene Spiele, durchwachsene Ergebnisse, aber es ist, glaube ich, so eine Mischung gewesen in der Hinrunde aus Über-Performance der Mannschaft und tatsächlich auch, dass keine Mannschaft eine richtige Konstanz obendrein hatte. Also wir bewegten uns gewissermaßen in so einem, es waren ja fast neun, zehn Mannschaften, die sich ungefähr innerhalb von drei, vier Punkten bewegten. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, eine Woche, auf die man gucken muss, was jetzt in der Rückschau ist tatsächlich Anfang Dezember gewesen, da gab es eine Niederlage gegen HSV, dann eine super unglückliche Pokalniederlage gegen Augsburg, für mich die beste Saisonleistung, wo der Schiedsrichter ja irgendwie vier Minuten nachspielen lässt in der Verlängerung und die dann noch ausgleichen und wir dann rausfliegen und dann halt eine herbe Derby-Klatsche gegen den FCK. Und das war so diese Dezemberwoche, wo vielleicht ein bisschen was zu Bruch gegangen ist. Danach gab es noch zwei Spiele gegen Regensburg, die waren damals so schlecht, dass man die einfach durch pure Intensität, sag ich mal, geschlagen hat. Und dann gab es noch diese, auch schon, muss man sagen, den glücklichen Sieg gegen Paderborn. Mit dieser PK, wo Quassenjog plötzlich sagt, ja, der KSC hat ja so viele Möglichkeiten und seine Mannschaft kommt viel zu kurz und seine Torhüter sind scheiße und so weiter und so fort. Wo er dann später rauskam, dass der HSV ja an ihm dran war und er beleidigt war und so weiter und so fort. Also was ich damit sagen will, es gab schon in der Hinrunde Anzeichen und für mich war die Hinrunde ein totales Geschenk, weil man darf den Sommer 2024 nicht unterschätzen. Die Abgänge, die Transferperiode und dass man dann so gut in die Saison kommt, rein punktemäßig, so eine tolle Hinrunde auch spielt, fand ich klasse. Ich kann ja mal aufzählen, Transferperiode 2024.
Ja, hol uns da gerne noch mal rein.
Was viele nicht auf dem Schirm haben, oder viele werden ihn mittlerweile auf dem Schirm haben, Paul Nebel war zwei Jahre ausgeliehen von Mainz. Und ich saß im April im Stadion gegen St. Pauli, eines der besten und intensivsten Zweitligaspiele der letzten Jahre, die ich gesehen habe, und dachte mir, was will Paul Nebel in der zweiten Liga? Der war damals schon auf einem Level. Der hat insgesamt bei uns in zwei Jahren neun Tore geschossen, hat jetzt in Mainz allein acht geschossen, schon gegen Dortmund letztes Wochenende. Wir haben Matanowicz verloren, den Top-Tor-Schützen, wo Boudou Tsivcivace so ein bisschen nebenher lief. Stintl hat seine Karriere beendet, Gondorff hat seine Karriere beendet, Prosinski hat seine Karriere beendet. Wir haben auch Tim Rossmann nach Büsseldorf verloren, darf man auch nicht unterschätzen, eigengewächst. Und Patrick Dreves hat den Verein verlassen als Torwart, unter anderem und so weiter und so fort. Und dafür sind gewissermaßen gekommen, eigentlich nur in dem ersten Zug, der mir richtig aufgefallen ist, das ist Robin Heuser von SV Wien-Wiesbaden, wo mir ganz viele Freunde geschrieben haben, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Das ist quasi so ein Sleeping-Giantransfer.
Habe ich auch damals geschätzt.
Den hatten ganz, ganz viele auch schon in der ersten Liga gesehen. Heidenheim muss da dran gewesen sein. Und unterm Strich muss man sagen, dass möglicherweise die letzte Transferperiode im Sommer nicht so gelaufen ist, wie man sich es wünscht. Und da sind wir gerade in der Phase, die sich, also noch mal so eine Transferperiode, sage ich mal, kann sich der KSC auch als Verein, der so vielleicht ein paar Jahrzehnte Vorsprung im Profifußball hat, gegenüber Elversberg jetzt nicht leisten. Weil ich habe so ein bisschen schmunzen müssen, Marc, als du das erzählt hast, wie so die Perspektive und die Herangehensweise ist, weil unter Sebastian frei ist. Und ist genau das die Herangehensweise zu sagen, wir brauchen eigentlich mehr junge Spieler, die man zu Geld machen kann. Die können gerne aus dem eigenen Nachwuchs kommen, passiert bei uns immer wieder. Man kann sie aber auch irgendwie von anderswo holen. Und das ist ja quasi der einzige krasse Unterschied, den ich bisher wahrgenommen habe zur Transferstrategie von Oliver Kreuzer. Dass man eher vom März auf junge Spieler setzt. Und lustigerweise, wir nehmen an dem Tag auf, beim zweijährigen Jubiläum von Oliver Kreuzer vom Rausschmiss. Das ist jetzt genau zwei Jahre her. Wir haben den 1. April und da hieß es ja auch damals in der Instagram oder in der Social Media Posting, es ist jetzt kein April-Scherz, Leute. Wir schmeißen das wirklich raus. Weil es wirklich total überraschend kam damals. Und ja, da muss man halt gucken. Also ich bin, kann man glaube ich über jeden Verein sagen, aber ich bin sehr gespannt auf den Sommer, weil der muss definitiv sitzen.
Wir werden über diese Mannschaften und über die Transfers reden, aber ein Name, den du ihm genannt hast, war Budozif Zivace. Der Mann hatte mit 12 Toren und 3 Vorlagen einen gehörigen Anteil daran, dass der KSC so weit oben geschwommen ist. In der Hinrunde hat den Verein aber dann im Winter verlassen, war ja auch die letzte Option für den KSC, eine Ablöse zu generieren, weil der Vertrag ausliefernd, glaube ich, auch schon klar war, dass er den nicht verlängern werden würde mit dieser Saison. Kann man den sportlichen Abfall in 2025 dann einzig an diesem Abgang festmachen oder haben da einfach so viele überperformt und diese Winterpause hat dann so ein bisschen an sich den Stecker gezogen?
Ja, ich glaube, das Thema ist definitiv komplexer, als es auf den ersten Blick herkommt. Ich habe vor kurzem eine Mitglieder-Forum, da kam das natürlich als erste Frage, wie kann man da BUDU verkaufen, wie kann man da quasi alle Aufstiegschancen wegschmeißen de facto. Aber ich sage es mal so, der BUDU, das gehört auch zur Wahrheit bei ihm, hat in jeder Transferperiode im Abgang kokettiert, immer eigentlich, hat schon im September frühzeitig gesagt, dass er seinen Vertrag auf keinen Fall verlängern wird. Und wenn er dann quasi so offensiv im Winter an die Verantwortlichen herantritt, die Ablösesumme stimmt, dann muss man sich halt zweimal überlegen, was man macht. Und ich sage es mal so, dadurch, dass das– also das ist jetzt meine Perspektive auf das Thema– dadurch, dass das Teilnehmerfeld oder das Aufstiegsaspirantenfeld wirklich so eng war, garantiert ja quasi ein Verbleib von Budu Zivcivatse nicht unbedingt, dass man garantiert aufsteigt. Es erhöht die Wahrscheinlichkeit, natürlich, aber dass man eine Garantie hat, dass man aufsteigt und ihn deshalb aus Teufel komm raus hält, das habe ich so nicht gesehen. Möglicherweise, wenn der KSC 6, 7 Punkte Vorsprung gehabt hätte, erster, zweiter gewesen wäre, hätte sich, glaube ich, diese Frage nach dem Abgang gar nicht gestellt.
Und wie fandest du denn die Lösung? Weil ich finde, das gibt ja zwei Dinge. Das eine ist der Verkauf des Spielers, das war ja ein bisschen wie bei Hertha und Tarek Zabakowitsch. Du konntest den Verkauf des Spielers total verargumentieren, schon ein gewisses Alter, er hat die Chance, Bundesliga zu spielen, der Verein kassiert eine gute Ablösesumme. Aber die Frage, die auf der anderen Seite steht, ist ja, wer beerbt diesen Stürmer? Hertha hat nur Luca Stuhler damals geholt und dachte, mit ihm, Small Previllac und Florian Niederlechner könnte man trotzdem oben mitmischen, hat sich da verkalkuliert. Und der KSC hat dafür per Laie Mikkel Kaufmann zurückbekommen, der ja schon mal ein ziemlich gutes Jahr beim KSC hatte. Wie fandest du das denn dann gelöst?
Ich fand es relativ pragmatisch gelöst. Ich will noch eine Sache zu Budo ergänzen, was quasi neben dem sportlichen Wert definitiv eine Rolle gespielt hat, war das, was das mit der Mannschaft mental gemacht hat, finde ich. Das Spiel in Elversberg war ja am 31. Januar, da hat Warnizek– das war ja ein 2-2, da haben wir noch ein 2-2 aufgeholt, auch dank der individuellen Klasse von Marwil Warnizek– der hat da recht deutlich gesagt nach dem Spiel, ja, das beschäftigt die Mannschaft schon. Dass quasi einfach ein Mitspieler, der die Mannschaft schon auf ein anderes Level gehoben hat, plötzlich weg ist und irgendwie nicht so richtig Ersatz kommt. Ich fand das aber pragmatisch gelöst, weil der Mikkel Kaufmann, der kennt Christian Eichner, kennt den Verein und ich war da relativ zuversichtlich– Winterzugänge ist ja immer so eine Sache– ich war da relativ zuversichtlich, dass er das gut hinbekommt, weil er wenig Eingewöhnungszeit braucht, sage ich mal. Und von daher fand ich das eine sehr pragmatische Lösung, die für mich okay ist. Aber da sind wir wieder bei der Erwartungshaltung unterm Strich.
Ja, und ich hätte dich an sich noch gefragt, was die Ziele der laufenden Saison sind, denn wie gesagt, viel mehr geht nicht. Glaubst du, es wird jetzt einfach darum gehen, sich noch in die obere Tabellenhilfe zu schieben und dann vor allen Dingen auf sich für die neue Saison zu wappnen?
Also das wäre mein Ziel. Das sehe ich auch so. Was soll er auch anderes machen? Christian Eichner propagiert das auch vor jedem Spiel, klar. Der muss ja irgendwie die Spannung aufrechterhalten. Ich bin mir tatsächlich nur jetzt gerade nach dem Hertha-Spiel nicht mehr ganz so sicher, wie das weitergeht. Also es hört sich total schwammig an, aber ich wäre froh, so ordentlich wie möglich diese Saison zu Ende bekommen. Einen FCK nochmal ärgern, richtig? Und ja, den Rest muss man sehen. Ich fand es auch spannend bei der Diskussion, bei diesem Mitgliederforum tatsächlich, weil da gibt es ja dann immer die Leute, die sagen, ey, wir haben mit Ben Fairhart, ein Super-Nachwuchsspieler, 18 Jahre alt. Wir haben mit Pinto Pedrosa, den Rechtsverteidiger, 17 Jahre alt. Die kann man ja einfach mal reinschmeißen. Aber dann kommt genau dieses Argument mit dem TV-Geldern. Eigentlich müsste man gucken, so weit wie möglich oben zu stehen in der TV-Gelt-Tabelle, damit man da halt auch gewissermaßen Geld bekommt. Spannend fand ich, dass wir im U23-Sektor quasi zu den ersten Drittel der DFL-Vereine gehören und ungefähr zweieinhalb Millionen Euro Ausschüttung bekommen aus diesem U23-Topf, was wiederum für mehr junge Spieler sprechen wird. Man wird sehen. Also ein Saisonziel mag ich gar nicht mehr formulieren. Nackt, also beim HSV-Quinn. Aber das ist eine persönliche Sache von mir.
Dann lassen wir uns gerne vielleicht über die Zukunft reden. Wir haben auch nur begrenzt Zeit und ich habe das Gefühl, beim KSC blickt man bereits sehr klar in den kommenden Sommer und ich habe so drei Baustellen ausfindig gemacht. Den Trainer, der Geschäftsführer Sport und die Mannschaft, würde gerne diese Dinge mit dir einmal durchgehen. Fangen wir gerne mal mit dem Trainer an. An sich ja keine Baustelle, denn wenn du mich fragst, ist Christian Eichler einer der besten Trainer dieser Liga. Ich halte ihn für einen sehr kompetenten Trainer. Das Problem ist, das wissen ja andere auch. Er verlängerte vor kurzem ja erst sein Vertrag bis 2027. Das war aber eine monatelange Hängepartie, wenn man ehrlich ist. Und er spricht jetzt wieder sehr offen darüber, den Verein im Sommer verlassen zu können. Er sagt selber, das hat der dpa gesagt, ich schließe weder etwas aus, noch verspreche ich irgendetwas. Wir leben hier auf beiden Seiten eine gute Offenheit und Ehrlichkeit. Wenn dein Angebot käme, müsste es mich schon ab dem ersten Anruf so richtig packen. Und wenn der KSC dann sein Veto einlegen würde, wäre es für mich aber auch wunderbar weiter hier. Wie kommen solche Aussagen beim KSC an und wie blickst du auf diese Personalien?
Ich glaube, man nimmt sie zur Kenntnis, aber ich sage es mal so, vor kurzem saßen sie bei dieser Mitgliederbefragung auch alle auf einem Podium, also Präsident, Sportchef, der wirtschaftliche Leiter Michael Becker. Ich glaube, tatsächlich, Christian Eichner lebt einfach nur das, was er auch die ganze Zeit sagt, dass er im Endeffekt auch mit offenen Karten spielt, soweit es ihm halt geht in der Medienlandschaft, sage ich mal. Aber ich glaube, das Gespräch war in einem größeren Zusammenhang und da wird schon sehr klar deutlich, dass er der erste Ansprechpartner der KSC ist. Und ich gehe davon aus weiter, dass da im Sommer nicht großartig was passiert. Weil wenn man Christian Eichner kennt, der den Karlsruher studiert auf Lehramt und so weiter und so fort. Ich glaube, der braucht halt auch ein Umfeld, in dem er funktioniert. Er ist auch ein Familienmensch. Und da ist er sich, glaube ich, sehr klar, deshalb hat er das mit der Griffigkeit erwähnt. Das muss ihn schon volle Pulle packen. Er hat auch im selben Interview gesagt, er könnte sich auch das Ausland irgendwann mal vorstellen. Aber ich könnte mir vor, ja, das gehen wir jetzt in hätte, könnte, wäre Kategorien. Also ich glaube auch, dass er weiß, dass er noch Zeit hat auf dem Trainermarkt. Andererseits problematisch könnte es halt werden, am gewissen Punkt, wo er zu einer, wie soll man sagen, wo er quasi zu einer Bewertung der Gesamtsituation kommt, wo er sich quasi halt auch nicht mehr so richtig gewertet fühlt. In dem Sinne, dass er jedes Jahr was aufbaut und in jeder Sommertransferperiode wird es wieder eingerissen. Und er muss wieder 3, 4 Spieler ein halbes Jahr aufbauen, bis es wieder gut geht. Und da könnte er halt irgendwann die Geduld verlieren. Das könnte ich mir schon vorstellen. Weil er ärgert sich und ambitioniert, das auf jeden Fall. Aber ich glaube, jetzt im Sommer stellt sich die Frage noch nicht unbedingt.
Klar, er kann mit diesen Aussagen auch irgendwie seinen eigenen Wert unterstreichen, den Verein so ein bisschen kitzeln. Denn man sieht ja auch, allein wenn man auf die ausgegebenen Ablösen guckt und ähnliches, der KSC macht dahingehend keine großen Sprünge und stagniert dahingehend in dieser 2. Liga und wird von Team SV Elversberg und Co. vielleicht sogar eher überholt in Zukunft. Da kann so ein junger, ambitionierter Trainer schon sagen, Leute, ihr habt mich, dann lasst doch jetzt hier was aufbauen. Und mit solchen Aussagen kann man das natürlich ein bisschen herauskitzeln. Dass man sagen kann, ich kann auch woanders zur Not. Das macht einen Lukas Kwasniok auch bloß ein bisschen rumpeliger, sage ich mal.
Ja, und im Endeffekt, um das zu Ende zu bringen, nur einen Satz dazu. Im Endeffekt war das aber auch seine ganze, also die Argumentationslinie ist nicht neu. Das war im Endeffekt auch die ganze Zeit die Argumentationslinie während der Vertragsverhandlungen, die ja sich sehr lang gezogen haben. Also von daher ist es jetzt kein neuer Stand. Aber er wurde halt drauf angesprochen, dann sagt er was dazu. Klar.
Genau, genau. Ist mir halt jetzt erst untergekommen, wenn man nicht jeden Tag dran ist, dann horcht man da schon mal auf. Ein vielleicht noch viel, viel größeres Fragezeichen. Du hast schon das Jubiläum genannt. Die Nachfolge von Kreuzer. Das Amt des Geschäftsführers Sport ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren unbesetzt. Wieso? Also die erste Frage, wieso gelang es denn überhaupt nicht, diese Lücke bislang zu schließen? Das ist ja die erste interessante Frage.
Naja, und jetzt dreh ich mal den Spieß rum. Man muss sich überhaupt überlegen, ob bis vor kurzem das eben als Lücke in dem Sinn kommuniziert wurde. Da muss man ja auch mal ehrlich sein. Die haben quasi in Juni 2023– also erst hieß es, wir schmeißen den Kreuzer raus. Wir haben eigentlich die Eier legende Wollmichsau gesucht de facto. Es sollen TV-Gelder her, es sollen Spieler her, die Geld bringen und überhaupt soll man sportlich wieder Erfolg haben. Also es kann kein Sportdirektor der Welt quasi mit den Voraussetzungen, die man in Karlsruhe hat oder generell in der 2. Liga. Also das ist sehr schwierig, perspektivisch glaube ich. Und dann hat man gesagt, ja, man geht in so einen professionellen Prozess. Das ist, wie gesagt, stand vor zwei Jahren und plötzlich im Juni gab es ein Kandidat mit mutmaßlich Carsten Rotenbach, der hier im NLZ bei St. Pauli unterwegs ist. Gab es eine Indiskretion der Zeitung bzw. es wurde durchgesteckt an den Medien und dann hat Carsten Rotenbach wohl abgesagt damals im Juni vor zwei Jahren. Und dann hat der KSC aber eine neue Struktur erst mal präsentiert und hat gesagt, okay, Michael Becker, der eigentlich für die Wirtschaftlichkeit am Start ist als Geschäftsleiter, der ist quasi der starke Mann beim KSC und der hat drei Bereichsleiter unter sich. Und dann wurde erst im August 2023 Sebastian Freis als Bereichsleiter Profis gewissermaßen installiert. Und jeder weiß, wer Sportdirektoren kennt und mit denen schon zu tun hatte, weiß ganz genau, dass kein Sportdirektor mit Format, sage ich mal, ich will Sebastian Freis das Format nicht absprechen, aber keiner macht Bereichsleiter. Der will gleichberechtigt neben dem wirtschaftlichen Chef sein gewissermaßen. Und da war das gar kein Thema. Und jetzt hat der Präsident vor kurzem von den Mitgliedern darauf angesprochen, gesagt, ja, vor einem Jahr haben sie wieder angefangen, den Sportchef zu suchen. Also doch jetzt, oder wie? Und das Thema wird jetzt immer heißer, sage ich mal. Und was dazu kommt ist halt auch, das war mir gar nicht so bewusst bis vor kurzem, Sebastian Freys Vertrag läuft aus im Sommer. Das bedeutet, du suchst jetzt offiziell wieder einen Sportchef auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite macht der, der eigentlich die Transfers machen soll, läuft der Vertrag aus. Und das finde ich tatsächlich, dieses Vakuum können wir uns eigentlich nicht leisten. Mal gucken.
Thema Vorgriff auf den Sommer, Thema langfristige Kaderplanung. Definitiv. Du hast gesagt, es wird konkreter. Medien berichten, dass Olaf Rebbe, der zuletzt bei Nürnberg gehen musste, hoch im Kurs stehen soll. Auch Ex-HSVler Ralf Becker ist im Gespräch. Was für ein Profil braucht der Club deiner Meinung nach denn auf dieser Rolle?
Ich glaube, es kann nur einer werden, der quasi die Vorgaben erfüllen kann oder erfüllen will, die der Verein jetzt vor zwei Jahren gegeben hat. Weil es gab ja schon Strategiewechsel mit diesem, wir setzen mehr auf jüngere Spieler. Das sieht man glaube ich auch im letzten Sommer. Das sind vor allem Perspektivspieler, was ja auch ein Stück weit ein Gamble ist. Und der ist jetzt im letzten Winter nicht so richtig, im letzten Sommer nicht so richtig aufgegangen. Das auf jeden Fall. Und ja, also ich könnte mir schon, deshalb wundert es mich jetzt beispielsweise nicht, dass Olaf Rebbel so in der Verlosung ist, weil der konnte sich quasi sich profilieren mit der Geschichte jetzt in Nürnberg, wo er unfassbar viel Transfererlöse quasi erzeugt hat durch die Spieler, die er dort holte. Und im Endeffekt soll diese Vision weitergeführt werden, dass man eher auf die entwicklungsfähigen Spieler setzt, die Kohle reinbringen, dass man guckt, dass zwischen MLZ und Profimannschaft das weiterhin durchlässig bleibt beispielsweise. Aber es wird auch immer wieder betont, dass man einen Stamm zusammen hat, der das dann trägt. Und machen wir uns nichts vor, der Stamm ist auch endlich bei uns. Marvin Warnizek ist auch über 30 mittlerweile. Und von daher werden die Aufgaben auf den Sportchef zukommen, auf den neuen. Und schnellstmöglich braucht diese Mannschaft im Sommer so ein bisschen frischen Wind.
Da sind wir dann nämlich bei der dritten Baustelle der Mannschaft. Es laufen im Sommer immens viele Verträge aus, unter anderem von Christoph Kobalt, Leon Jensen, Robin Baumuth. Leon Jensen soll ja auch der Wechsel nach Berlin, die Rückkehr zu Hertha bevorstehen heißt es. Bei vielen Spielern weiß man nicht, wie lange die Verträge noch laufen. Da ist es nicht genau kommuniziert, habe ich nachgeguckt. Und dazu kommen ja aber auch zahlreiche Leinen, die enden werden. Das heißt, es steht am Ende des Tages ein riesiger Umbruch an. Wo soll denn die Reise dahin gehen? Welche Vision hat der KSC für den Kader? Du hast ja schon gesagt, es soll mehr in Richtung junge, entwicklungsfähige Spieler gehen, die für Profit gehen können. Aber ja, jetzt ist aktuell sogar die Frage, wer baut diesen Kader überhaupt? Also, wo setzt man da überhaupt an? Also, ich finde, das ist gerade ein großes Wirrwarr.
Ja, und das ist halt vor allem auch eine spannende Frage, weil man ja sich tatsächlich auch in den letzten Jahren wirtschaftlich konsolidiert hat. Deshalb werden natürlich auch die Stimmen laut, die sagen, man muss so ein bisschen mehr in den Kader investieren. Weil ich finde schon, dass der letzte Sommer so extrem aus Perspektive gebaut wird. Und ich glaube halt schon, dass man Spieler braucht, die direkt funktionieren und helfen auf jeden Fall. Es sind zumindest zwei oder drei. Und darum kann man eben auch noch mal jüngere Spieler bauen. Dass man ja auch nie vergessen darf, die Spieler, die im letzten Sommer geholt wurden, die können ja irgendwann schon noch funktionieren. Manchmal klappt das ja auch erst in der zweiten Saison. Die können rangeführt werden. Ich glaube, der Robin Häuser, der wird uns nächste Saison enorm helfen. Der war bis zum 10. Spieltag raus und geht jetzt so langsam auf, sag ich mal, gewöhnt sich vielleicht an Eichner und so weiter oder ans neue Umfeld.
Das kann schon sein und David Herold ist ja auch noch sehr jung, der Linksverteidiger.
Genau, aber da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, was die ganze Kaderplanung wieder zerschießen kann, dass so Leute wie Herold Beifuß oder auch Max Weiß, der jetzt im Tor steht, direkt wieder im Sommer Verkaufskandidaten sein werden. Das definitiv. Max Weiß zum Beispiel ist der Torwart in der zweiten Liga, der mit Abstand den größten Marktwert hat. Der ist 3 Millionen wert laut Transfermarkt, wenn man das so als Einordnung mal nehmen will. Und tatsächlich wird er jetzt auch nicht seit gestern erst mit Wolfsburg in Verbindung gebracht. Von daher steht ein eigengewächstes Tor nach einem Jahr direkt wieder weg, so nach dem Motto. Beifuß hat sich geweigert, seinen Zertrag zu verlängern. Den müsste man dann wahrscheinlich auch ins Schaufenster stellen und so weiter. Also sprich, Leute, auf die du gesetzt hast, sind möglicherweise auch im Sommer wieder weg. Das wäre quasi eine weitere Baustelle bei den Transferbemühungen. Und deshalb war meine Hoffnung, und da wäre ich dann schon enttäuscht, wenn das nicht so kommen würde, dass der neue Sportchef dann tatsächlich das Geld, das man durch Budo, Zivci, Waze und so weiter eingenommen hat, auch im Sommer mal ein bisschen investiert. Weil es hieß tatsächlich auch bei dieser Neuausrichtung, dass alles, was im Sport generiert wird, auch wieder in den Sport reinfließen wird. Das hat Michael Becker extra noch mal gesagt. Und dann, ich kann die Entscheidung, die strategische, total nachvollziehen, dass man sagt, wir ersetzen den Budo durch ein Leihgeschäft, bringen die Saison vernünftig zu Ende. Aber dann möchte ich aber auch im Sommer so ein bisschen, ja, also was heißt, ein bisschen was sehen. Aber ich mache mir langsam Sorgen, weil tatsächlich habe ich so das Gefühl, dass der Kader sich zurückentwickelt ein bisschen. Dafür spricht ja auch die aktuelle Tabellenplatzierung mit Platz 7, Platz 5 in den letzten Jahren. Das wird es definitiv nicht dieses Jahr. Also im Sommer muss sich definitiv was tun.
Definitiv. Es bleiben ja gar nicht so viele Korsettstange. Also klar, Marcel Franke durfte bleiben, so ein Nikolaj Rapp durfte bleiben, Marwin Warnizek sowieso und vorne vielleicht so ein Fabian Schleusener.
Der hat noch Vertrag, genau.
Der hat noch Vertrag. Ich glaube, Sebastian Jung auch?
Sebastian Jungs Vertrag wurde verlängert und das muss man sich auch mal überlegen, dass wirklich einer mit den konstantesten… Also Sebastian Jung ist so ein super Kicker. Marwin Warnizek, da können wir echt froh sein, dass der seine gesundheitlichen Probleme in den Griff bekommen hat. Der wird auch bleiben. Aber Jahrgang 90. Achso.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Okay, tja. Ich glaube, das schreit einfach nach noch einem Treffen hier beim KSC im Rasenfunk, weil wir jetzt, glaube ich, eher einfach offen gelegt haben, wie viele Fragezeichen es in diesem Verein gibt, die man jetzt gar nicht mit Gewissheit beantworten kann. Aber eine potenzielle vierte Baustelle, wenn du zu Gast bist, muss ich natürlich abfragen. Gibt es Neues aus dem Haus auf Karlsruhe? Oder ist es in den Gremien zur Abwechslung mal ein bisschen ruhiger?
Nö, zurzeit ist es ein bisschen ruhig. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es jederzeit da mit Sportdirektor-Entscheidungen und so wieder ein bisschen aufploppt. Also vorerst, die letzten Ausläufer waren vielleicht so die Sache mit Jérôme Gondorff, der plötzlich geklagt hat, dass sein Vertrag sich doch angeblich verlängert hätte und so weiter.
Das habe ich mitbekommen.
Ja, und es wurde dann irgendwie abgeschmettert, weil alle gesagt haben, ja, nee, es ist einfach ausgelaufen. Und da ist er jetzt ja auch öffentlichkeitswirksam in einem Interview zu Kreuzer gekocht. Das war so das Spannendste, was so abseits des Rasens, sage ich mal, zu diesem House of Karlsruhe in letzter Zeit passiert ist. Und ich glaube schon, dass es schon damit zu tun hatte, ein Stück weit.
Dann dadurch, dass wir nicht wissen, wo die Reise genau hingeht, möchte ich mir von dir eine Utopie bauen lassen. Was wäre denn für dich, wenn also quasi Sommer 2026, die quasi nächste Saison ist gespielt, die alle Personalien sind entschieden, was müsste passieren, dass du sagst, das war ein erfolgreiches Jahr, jetzt gehen wir wieder mit Perspektive in die nächsten Jahre. Was muss dafür in der Saison auf den Schaltpositionen, in den Gremien und so weiter passiert sein unter dem Kader?
Naja, also ideal fände ich, wenn sie ihn jetzt schon holen wollen, fände ich natürlich erstmal einen Sportchat super, der dann quasi auch erkennbar erste Dinge in die Wege geleitet hat, dass man beispielsweise einen Spielertyp wie Mantanowicz mal 2-3 Jahre halten kann, wie zuletzt Philipp Hoffmann, der war ja schon einige Zeit da, bevor der nach Bochum ist, dass man da halt auch irgendwie eine klare Tendenz erkennt und dass möglicherweise auch junge Spieler auch ein, zwei Jahre erstmal nochmal durchziehen, damit irgendwie zumindest die Mannschaft, damit man auch das Gespür bekommt, die Mannschaft geht wieder quasi in eine gute Richtung, in Anführungszeichen. Also ich würde jetzt sagen, es ist noch nicht entschieden, in welche Richtung es geht, aber aktuell birgt die Situation durchaus Gefahren, dass es quasi doch wieder in eine andere Richtung gehen kann, wo man dachte eigentlich ist immer da weg. Das würde ich mir sehr wünschen.
Ich finde ja, es gibt ein paar echt spannende Talente beim KSC. Max Weiß, wie gesagt, muss man gucken, ob der nicht den Verein direkt wieder verlässt. Aber ich habe ja jetzt auch Ben Verhard in Berlin gesehen. Ich finde, das war noch mit der auffälligste, der ja auch eine gute Chance hatte. Oder auch, wie du gesagt hast, Pinto Pedrosa auf rechts, aber ja auch glaube ich ein aktuell verletzter Schiller Roklu. Der ist ja auch nicht ganz verkehrt, glaube ich. Also dahingehend passiert ja wieder mehr. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass so aus der U23 und U19 vor allem vom KSC wieder mehr produziert wird. Das war eine Zeit lang gefühlt auch, naja, weniger zumindest.
Und da habe ich natürlich ein letztes Saisonhighlight, das habe ich komplett vergessen, wenn du schon die U19 ansprichst. Pokalfinale am 23.05. in Potsdam gegen Werder Bremen. Da freue ich mich drauf, werde ich auch hinfahren.
Schau an, schau an. Schön, im Schalem von Turbine dann, oder?
Wo findet das statt? Ja, genau, Babelswerk da.
Ja, nett. Ja, nett. Ja, da schaue ich vielleicht da auch vorbei. Das klingt ja eigentlich ganz glanzig.
Hol mal ein Pokal endlich mal wieder.
Was war der letzte Titel? Die Drittligameisterschaft? Ist man damals überhaupt noch im Aufstieg Meister geworden?
Ja, ich glaube, ja. Einmal ist man Meister geworden, aber wir haben das Halbmasters in den 90ern gewonnen und davor zweimal Pokal im 50ern.
Ich sehe es. Die deutsche Drittligameisterschaft 2012, 2013 war der letzte Titel. Was war der letzte Titel in Elversberg, Marc?
Die sind ja gar nicht so lange her. Drittliga-Aufstieg, 2. Liga-Aufstieg, erst das zweite Jahr 2. Liga. Dann gibt es noch diverse Saarland-Pokalsiege, die sie eine Reihe feiern durften, bevor sie in die 2. Liga aufgestiegen sind. Also, wir müssen nicht so viel, wir können doch nicht in die 50er zurückgehen, weil da gab es das nicht so. Also, die jüngsten Erfolge sind tatsächlich dann die beiden Aufstiege in Serie. Plus, es waren, glaube ich, jeweils Dubelsiege, also jeweils Pokalsiege noch dazu.
Verstehe. Gut, dann machen wir diese Sendung doch rund und schauen. Und ich bedanke mich an dieser Stelle bei Jörn Kreuzer und Marc Drumm für eure Zeit. Das hat ganz großen Spaß gemacht. Ich habe sehr viel gelernt, besonders natürlich über Elversberg. Das ist ja manchmal noch ein bisschen unbeschriebeneres Blatt als der KSC, den man ja schon gut kennt. Vielen lieben Dank an euch beide.
Total gern. Vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Und ansonsten bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch zu sagen, unterstützt diesen Podcast sehr gerne, rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Schaut in die Kontoumstellung. Show notes, ganz wichtig. Und dann hören wir uns das nächste Mal, ja, in vielleicht sogar schon zwei Wochen. Wer weiß, übernimmt Eva, übernehme ich. Wir werden es sehen. Macht's gut und eine schöne Restwoche. Bis dann.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.